do you ever think now that you would put
your family in a reality show like would
you do that nowadays I don't I don't
know and the reason I would Pro I'm
probably leaning towards no and the only
reason being is like I want my kids to
be kids for as long as possible enjoy it
like we but even when they were in it
you know there's another sister Amy who
didn't choose to be in it so they and
you guys kind of really nice I hear from
I think it's pretty well known that
Courtney has not wanted to be on the
Kardashians for many years and said she
doesn't want to be in it and kind of
forced to be on the show I think it's
really nice that it was I I don't buy
that you don't well cuz where's Rob
Kardashian he checked out I know but he
was never part of the three sisters that
got like no he was the he was he there
he was in there at the beginning he was
in he was a he he was a big deal for so
you don't believe that she doesn't
actually want to be on the show and
that's like you think I think she can
not show up yeah I I 100% think that the
way that that business is structured
they all have to they they yeah they
have to just continue to feed the beast
were you ever once you signed on and
were involved in it was there a time
when you went holy 100% without a
doubt there was a lot that's why we
ended it after three and a half Seasons
we just couldn't wasn't
sustainable it was two things it was it
was taking a huge toll on on I think
everyone's mental psyche why tell me
what with well it was like we we went to
bed Rel you know we went to bed known
amongst the music world but not in this
in the in the way of
like not being able to walk down the
street or getting follow cuz my dad
although my dad has been well known for
many many many years is he was rock and
roll famous he wasn't TV famous and it
was as you know that's a very different
thing especially back then when right
all it was was was TV radio movie there
was no internet there was no so you
didn't enjoy that I would think a young
guy who was going into the clubs at
first I did at first it was great and
then it it was Pandora's Box because I I
kind of fell into you know fell into
drugs alcohol all just those usual you
know Hollywood tropes of childhood
success you don't think you would have
done it if you weren't on TV I don't
think I I think it just sped it up I
think it just gave me the the the means
and the access that I wouldn't have had
if I was just still buming around on you
know Sunset Strip finding
bands
I